Hi, Josh Craig and Alec.
嗨，乔什、克雷格和亚历克。
This is Mason coming at you from Kansas.
我是梅森，从堪萨斯发来的。
Last night I finished my first watching of How I Met Your Mother and it has impacted me deeper than anything.
昨晚我第一次看完了《老爸老妈浪漫史》，它对我的影响超过了任何东西。
I do love the finale.
我很喜欢大结局。
I will say that a little over a year ago, a month after my 18th birthday, my family lost my father suddenly and I totally lost faith in everything.
我得说，一年多前，就在我18岁生日后一个月，我的家人突然失去了父亲，我彻底对一切失去了信念。
and myself and the universe, my relationships, everything.
对我自己、对宇宙、对我的各种关系，对一切。
In December, I discovered your show during the darkest part of my life.
十二月，在我生命中最黑暗的时期，我发现了你们的节目。
And I can confidently say that since the beginning, since I've started to resonate with Ted and his character, your show has been the greatest tool to aid me in regaining faith in society of the universe, myself, everything.
我可以自信地说，从一开始，自从我开始与泰德和他的角色产生共鸣以来，你们的节目就成为了帮助我重塑对社会、宇宙、自我以及一切的信念的最伟大工具。
I cannot thank you guys enough for the incredible impact your show has made on me just in the past six months and for the many, many, many years to come.
我怎么感谢你们都不为过，感谢你们的节目在过去短短六个月里对我产生的影响，以及在未来漫长岁月里的影响。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
I'm a low, won't be super city, let us see, permit me to tell you everything, book city.
我是一个卑微的人，不会去大城市，让我们看看，请允许我告诉你一切，图书城。
Welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother, I'm Josh Radner, I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas, hey Craig.
欢迎收听另一期的《我们是如何创造你们的母亲》的，我是乔什·拉德纳，我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里，嘿，克雷格。
Hey Josh, my God.
嘿，乔什，天哪。
I like it just making us cry at the start of every episode now, that's what's happening.
我喜欢现在每集开头都让我们哭，事情就是这样。
Look, there's a lot of great sitcoms out there that bring a lot of joy to people.
听着，外面有很多伟大的情景喜剧，给人们带来很多欢乐。
I just can't imagine if they solicit letters from viewers that many of them are hearing that kind of stuff.
我只是无法想象，如果他们向观众征求来信，会有多少人听到这种东西。
It's just extraordinary.
这简直太非同寻常了。
I don't even know, I need to lie down for five minutes.
我甚至不知道，我需要躺下五分钟。
Can I just, can we just take a break?
我能，我们能休息一下吗？
I mean, that's a perfect example of what we're talking about and what we've been talking about since day one on this show is like the secret soul medicine that's in this show where this show reaches people in dark times and hard times and gives them some sort of, I don't know, like will to go on, it restores faith in people, in the world, society, like he said, we're just bold over, thank you so much for sharing that, we're so sorry for your loss.
我的意思是，这正是我们一直在谈论的完美例子，也是我们从这个节目第一天起就在谈论的，就像这个节目中蕴含的秘密灵魂药剂，在这个节目在黑暗时期和艰难时期触及人们并给他们某种力量，我不知道，比如继续前进的意志，它恢复了人们对人、对世界、对社会的信念，就像他说的，我们简直惊呆了，非常感谢你分享这些，对于你的损失我们深感遗憾。
So sorry for your loss, my God, that's really hard, thank you for sharing that with us.
对你的损失深表遗憾，天哪，这真的很艰难，谢谢你与我们分享这些。
I mean, that's an honor that you would share that with us and open up, the show being there for you is like our dream come true as artists, and all we can say is thanks for like letting that in and then sharing that story with us.
我的意思是，你能与我们分享并敞开心扉，这是一种荣幸，节目能陪伴着你就像我们作为艺术家的梦想成真一样，我们能说的一切就是感谢你接受它，然后与我们分享这个故事。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
Yeah, thank you.
是的，谢谢。
So before we dive into this week's episode, which is episode eight, season three, it's called spoiler alert.
所以在我们深入探讨本周的剧集之前，也就是第三季第八集，名叫“剧透”。
It was written by help me out.
它是被写出来的，帮帮我。
Stephen Lloyd.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德。
Stephen Lloyd, almost there door to door.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德，差不多是元老了。
He's the third.
他是第三个。
It goes Chris Harris, Courtney Kang, Stephen Lloyd's about the longest third longest serving.
从克里斯·哈里斯、考特尼·康，斯蒂芬·劳埃德是资历第三长的。
How much?
有多少？
He arrives slightly into season one.
他在第一季刚开始时加入。
Well, get to it, but a fantastic cameo at the end.
好吧，我们等下会讲到，结尾有一个精彩的客串。
He is in the episode, we'll get there.
他在这集里，我们等下会讲到。
Terrific.
太棒了。
Alec, when did this episode air?
亚历克，这一集是什么时候播出的？
Originally on November 12th, 2007.
最初于2007年11月12日播出。
Man.
天哪。
Well, before we get into this episode, which is a really fun episode, I think we need to talk about the big news of our personal lives, me and Craig's personal lives.
好吧，在我们进入这一集之前，这是一集非常有趣的剧集，我想我们需要谈谈我们个人生活中的重大新闻，我和克雷格的个人生活。
We are, if all goes well, the stars align.
我们，如果一切顺利，群星闪耀。
I'm so nervous to even say it out loud.
我甚至紧张得不敢大声说出来。
Do we say it?
我们要说吗？
I'm not sure we can say it, but I think we're too far in now.
我不确定我们能不能说，但我认为我们现在陷得太深了。
There's no correct.
没有正确的。
There's no turn back.
没有回头路。
Craig Taliesin and I are having dinner in Brooklyn tonight.
克雷格·塔利辛和我今晚要在布鲁克林共进晚餐。
Finally, after we, I realized Craig, I've gone through- It's a salad three months.
终于，在我意识到克雷格之后，我经历过——这是一场长达三个月的沙拉。
It's a salad three months.
这是一场长达三个月的沙拉。
I've gone through two assistants trying to schedule this meal for us.
我换了两个助理才为我们预约好这顿饭。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
I think it broke Lola.
我觉得这把萝拉逼疯了。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
Yes, she's forgotten it.
是的，她已经忘了。
She's gone.
她走了。
She could handle it.
她应付不来。
bring in Sam, but we got it on the books in a couple hours.
换了萨姆上，但我们在几个小时内就把它定下来了。
I should be sitting across from the actual.
我应该坐在真正的……对面。
This ship is unsingable.
这艘船是沉不了的。
We're definitely having this dinner tonight.
我们今晚绝对要吃这顿饭。
What could possibly go wrong?
到底能出什么差错呢？
Yeah, well, I am sick.
是的，好吧，我生病了。
I am powering through.
我在硬撑。
You are sick.
你生病了。
They made me very nervous by telling me you're a little under it.
他们告诉我你有点不舒服，这让我非常紧张。
Well, I started the antibiotics, but I said I'd be like, I'd be like sick Barney.
嗯，我开始吃抗生素了，但我说我会像，我会像生病的巴尼一样。
I'd be like, you know, I'm not sick.
我会像，你知道的，我没生病。
You're not sick.
你没生病。
This is fucking happening, man.
这他妈的正在发生，伙计。
We're doing it.
我们在做了。
It's happening.
正在发生。
We're doing it.
我们在做了。
Okay.
好的。
I went and saw Death of Salesman last night with my friend, it's terrific, great production.
昨晚我和我朋友去看《推销员之死》，太棒了，制作精良。
Nathan Lane, Laurie Metcalfe.
内森·连恩，劳里·梅特卡夫。
What a cast, who should I run out?
多么强大的演员阵容，我该撞上谁呢？
Run into, in front of the theater, we were both waiting for our dates to show up.
在剧院前面偶遇，我们俩都在等我们的约会对象出现。
Then Roger Bart from...
然后是罗杰·巴特，来自……
Does your dad know about this?
你爸爸知道这事吗？
I was meeting a friend of my friend, Oscar.
我是去见我朋友奥斯卡的。
But Roger Barte, who played the clerk at the end.
但是罗杰·巴特，他在最后饰演那个职员。
I think his name is Curtis at the end.
我想他最后叫柯蒂斯。
At the end.
最后。
We're jumping way ahead to season 90s.
我们直接跳到了第90季。
He's repeatedly seen throughout the ninth season, which is set all over the cross the weekend in a hotel.
他在第九季中多次出现，背景设定在周末的酒店里。
And he was a great sort of fixture of that season.
他是那一季的一个重要常驻角色。
That's cool.
这太酷了。
It was great to see him.
很高兴见到他。
And I reminded him and he remembered exactly, do you remember the table read?
我提醒了他，他完全记得，你还记得那次剧本围读吗？
He was late because security somehow didn't have his name.
他迟到了，因为安保不知为何没有他的名字。
Do you remember this?
你还记得这个吗？
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
对，对，没错。
And he remembered exactly what his entrance line was because he had one of the greatest entrances ever because there's like 45 people in that room.
他准确地记得他的出场台词是什么，因为他有史上最棒的出场之一，因为那个房间里有大约45个人。
And if you're a guest star and you're late.
如果你是一个客串明星而且你迟到了。
Oh, it's horrifying.
哦，太可怕了。
Yeah, I'm mortifying, yeah.
是的，太丢脸了，是的。
So he came in, he's like, he's sweating.
所以他进来了，他像，他在流汗。
And he said, I'm so sorry, security, obviously, wasn't familiar with my work.
他说，非常抱歉，安保显然对我的作品不太熟悉。
That's a good line.
这是一句好台词。
It's a great line.
这是一句极好的台词。
It diffused everything.
它化解了一切。
But it was great to see him.
但能见到他真是太好了。
And you know, it's fun to be in New York.
而且你知道的，在纽约很有趣。
I mean, like, if you're in New York or LA, you run into how I met your mother, players over.
我的意思是，比如你在纽约或洛杉矶，你会遇到《老爸老妈浪漫史》的演员们。
It's so cool.
这太酷了。
It's such a vast array of people we have forgotten, like every now and again, it's like, oh yeah, that guy's a dispersant in the show.
有那么多我们已经忘记的形形色色的人，比如时不时地，就会想，哦对，那家伙在剧里客串过。
It's cool, nine seasons is very, the gift of nine seasons is we got some people.
这很酷，九季的剧集，九季带来的礼物就是我们有很多演员。
We got some people in the show and some music on this show.
我们在剧中有很多演员，还有一些剧中的音乐。
It's very, it's very cool.
这真的，真的很酷。
Doesn't happen anymore.
现在不会再有了。
And also like, you guys would really plunder Broadway.
而且就像，你们真的会去百老汇“大肆搜罗”。
I mean, there were a lot of like great theater actors.
我的意思是，有很多优秀的戏剧演员。
With no greater example than Kristin Milliotti, who we saw in one song Broadway, and we were absolutely stealing Broadway.
最好的例子莫过于克里斯汀·米利奥蒂，我们在百老汇的一场演出中看到了她，而我们绝对是在百老汇挖墙脚。
people left and right, including her.
到处都是人，包括她。
Yeah, that's fantastic.
是的，太棒了。
Great.
太棒了。
So this episode is really fun.
所以这一集真的很有趣。
Why don't you give us your little summary of what happens in this episode, Craig?
克雷格，你能不能给我们简单总结一下这一集发生了什么？
This is a good little sort of everyone's on the same train episode, right?
这是一个很好的、大家都在同一条船上的那种剧集，对吧？
We so much talk about the ABC thing.
我们经常谈论ABC的那个事情。
This is the sort of game of dominoes off of this one observation that when you love someone or you're infatuated with someone and you may not see a flaw of theirs, but once somebody gives you the gift slash curse of pointing that flaw out, you can't unsee it.
这就像是一场多米诺骨牌效应，源于这样一个观察：当你爱一个人或迷恋一个人时，你可能看不到对方的缺点，但一旦有人给了你指出这个缺缺点这一“礼物加诅咒”，你就再也无法忽视它了。
And it's sort of like this opening dominoe falls where Ted is dating a new woman played by Lindsey Price.
这就有点像第一块多米诺骨牌倒下了，泰德正在和林赛·普莱斯饰演的新女性约会。
He's great.
她很棒。
And Ted doesn't see her flaw.
而泰德没有看到她的缺点。
And when it gets pointed out to him, it sort of destroys everything and results.
当这个缺点被指出来时，它几乎摧毁了一切并导致了结果。
And again, these dominoes tipping over of everyone pointing out each others.
并且再次，这些多米诺骨牌接连倒下，每个人都在指出彼此的缺点。
Now, now everyone's returns on each other.
现在，每个人的回报都落在了彼此身上。
He's had this woman and ruined for him, and then everyone starts calling each other out on their things, and that I didn't spoil it.
他得到了这个女人却被毁了，然后每个人都开始揭发彼此的事情，我可没剧透。
It's a little like the Spider-Man meme where everyone's pointing at each other.
这有点像那个蜘蛛侠互指的梗。
It's the Spider-Man.
就是那个蜘蛛侠。
This episode, it emplays the narrative structure of Spider-Man meme, which I don't think we even know at the time.
这一集，它采用了蜘蛛侠梗的叙事结构，我觉得当时我们甚至都不知道这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
But also, it's another episode where it starts with a mystery, like we don't see the problem.
但同时，这也是另一集以谜团开场的故事，就好像我们看不到问题所在。
What is the thing?
到底是怎么回事？
Why is everyone snapping at her?
为什么每个人都对她发脾气？
She seems perfectly pleasant.
她看起来非常随和。
I said that.
我是这么说的。
我当时就这么说。
with my wife last night, it was like mini-mystery, right?
昨晚我和我妻子看的时候，就像是一个微型谜团，对吧？
Right in the cold open, right at the beginning of the show, you're like, what is this?
就在冷开场，在剧集刚开始的时候，你就会想：这到底是什么？
There's something we are going on here.
这里面肯定有些什么情况。
What do we, we're in Ted's shoes, we don't know what's wrong either.
我们代入泰德的视角，我们也不知道哪里不对劲。
And the audience is very much, I mean, I always thought I was a portal, my character was a portal for the audience, but very much in this one, because the audience is just as confused as him, because you withhold, I mean, how many of your mother was like?
而且观众非常有……我的意思是，我一直以为我是个通道，我的角色是观众的通道，但在这一集里尤其如此，因为观众和他一样困惑，因为你们有所保留，我是说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》有多少次是这样的？
It's legitimately confusing, and so good at withholding information, you know?
这真的让人困惑，而且你们在隐瞒信息方面太有一套了，你知道吗？
It's on a need-to-know basis.
这是按需知悉的。
It is, the whole beginning of the episode is maddening.
确实，这一集的整个开头都让人抓狂。
And I kind of forgot what it was gonna be.
我有点忘了后来会发生什么。
I hadn't watched this one in years.
这一集我好几年没看了。
And I was like, what is her thing again?
然后我就想：她到底有什么毛病来着？
And then I was like on the edge of my seat.
接着我看得心潮澎湃。
I was like, right, right.
我心想：对，没错。
She talks me too much.
她跟我说得太多了。
And we've abridged that in the cold open, but later we see the fullness of what she was really saying.
我们在开场白里删节过，但后来我们看到了她真正想表达的完整内容。
Have you ever had the experience of a dear friend dating someone that drove you bonkers?
你有没有过这种经历：好朋友在跟一个让你抓狂的人谈恋爱？
Or did you tell them or not tell them?
或者你有没有告诉过他们，还是没说？
And what is your feeling about the ethics of telling someone that.
你对把这种事告诉别人的道德看法是什么？
I mean, Ted is devastated when he finds out, right?
我是说，泰德发现的时候整个人都崩溃了，对吧？
Was he, was he, but I guess you could argue it either way.
他是吗，真的是吗？不过我想你可以从各个角度来争论。
Like are his friends doing him a service and saying, you'll see this eventually.
比如他的朋友是不是在帮他，说你以后就会明白了。
So we're just going to fast forward here.
所以我们这里直接快进。
You're in the infatuation.
你正处于迷恋之中。
I like that idea of the goggles.
我挺喜欢那种“滤镜”的说法。
What does Marne say or the shoot?
马恩说了什么来着？或者说……
I'm forgetting.
我给忘。
You want to have sex goggles or whatever.
你想说的是“荷尔蒙滤镜”什么的。
Whatever it was like the idea of like, we're just going to take these things off here and just kind of tell you what's up.
不管怎样，就像是：我们要把这些东西拿掉，然后直接告诉你真相。
So I guess they think they're doing Ted a service, but I don't know, what do you think the ethics are?
所以我想他们觉得自己是在帮泰德的忙，但我不知道，你觉得这里的道德界限在哪里？
I mean, people should be allowed to discover it for themselves, and maybe they never will discover it, and then that's who you should marry, I guess, because you love them so much, and so for so in such an enduring way that you never see their flaw, or you embrace their flaw.
我是说，应该允许人们自己去发现，也许他们永远不会发现，那我想这就是你该结婚的人，因为你如此深爱着对方，以至于这种爱历久弥新，让你永远看不到对方的缺点，或者你能够包容他们的缺点。
I don't know, I found myself wondering about this philosophical question too.
我不知道，我也曾纳闷过这个哲学问题。
You know, it's funny, someone, I don't want to get into specifics, but someone we both know, I broke up with a girlfriend.
你知道，这很有趣，有个——我不想扯到具体细节，但我们都认识的一个人，我跟一个女朋友分手了。
This is in like the later seasons and she was not on the show.
这是在比较后面的几季，而且她没有在节目里出现。
She was like, no one, you know, but this person, this mutual friend of ours said, oh, good.
她就像是……没人认识，但这个人，我们的一个共同朋友说，哦，太好了。
You don't want to be with her, right?
你不想跟她在一起，对吧？
And she went home and her husband said, you can never say that to someone.
然后她回家后，她丈夫说，你绝不能对别人说这种话。
And she said, why is it?
然后她说，为什么？
What if they get back together?
万一他们复合了呢？
Yeah.
对啊。
And we got back together.
然后我们复合了。
Oh my God.
我的天哪。
We got back together for about seven or eight months.
我们复合了大概七八个月。
And I think she was pretty horrified.
我想她当时肯定吓坏了。
But wait, wait, wait, wait did in that moment where she said that your friend said that wasn't where the flaws pointed out Was it like good you can't be with her cuz barra or was the canner worms wasn't open?
等等，等等，在你朋友说那话的那个时刻，是不是没有指出具体的缺点？是像“太好了，你不能跟她在一起，因为巴拉巴拉”这样的，还是说潘多拉的魔盒根本没打开？
No She just thought it was she just more thought it wasn't a match.
不，她只是觉得……她更倾向于认为俩人不合适。
She didn't like okay It wasn't like quite spoiler alert.
她不喜欢……好吧，不算是什么剧透警告。
It wasn't this mechanism.
机制不是这样的，不是那种情况，但就感觉有点棘手。
It wasn't not that but it was like a little tough You're walking a fine line here, Fred.
弗雷德，你这是在走钢丝啊。
Yeah You're gonna tell me a dinner with the full story.
行，你得在吃晚饭时把完整的故事告诉我。
I can't wait for dinner now Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
我现在等不及要吃晚饭了。嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，播客《Hyper-Fixed》的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的难题并试着帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这些问题：我30岁了，但不敢在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我挂倒挡时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐藏系统。
That's the hyper-fixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的播客《Hyper-Fixed》。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或hyperfixedpod.com上找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
I think it's one thing when you're casually dating someone.
我觉得当你只是随便约会时是一回事。
It's another thing if there's like a ring has been presented.
如果已经求婚了，那就是另一码事了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Hey, right, this is a very different question depending on where in the timeline we are.
嘿，对啊，这取决于我们处于时间线的哪个阶段，这是一个完全不同的问题。
Because Ted has just met this woman.
因为泰德才刚刚认识这个女人。
And I guess you can sort of say it.
我想你大概可以这么说。
And to be fair, they were not telling him until he prided out of them.
而且平心而论，他们一开始没告诉他，直到他逼问出来。
And it's very funny, his buyer's remorse once he knows, like, why did you tell me?
而且很有趣，他知道了之后的这种买家后悔症，就像是，你为什么要告诉我？
You know I didn't really want to know which to Marshall.
你知道我其实并不想知道马歇尔的这个缺点。
But also, I think if Barney or Robin or Lily, one of them thought this, he might have been able to brush it off.
但同时，我觉得如果是巴尼、罗宾或莉莉，他们其中一人这么想，他可能还能不放在心上。
The uniformity of the opinion around this thing is so strong.
大家对这件事的看法竟然如此一致。
It's like his four best friends in the world are like, she won't stop talking, this is unbearable.
就好像他世界上最好的四个朋友都在说，她喋喋不休，这简直让人无法忍受。
Yeah.
是啊。
It must have been where do you guys come up with the, is it like the, the glass breaking or the mirror breaking?
当时你们是怎么想出那个概念的，是类似玻璃碎裂还是镜子碎裂？
Yeah.
对。
Just, just, just the idea of like you can't put it back together again.
就是，就是，那种一旦破了就无法复原的想法。
Just that idea like it's something has, and illusion, as an illusion has shattered and you can't put it by, we're, we're looking for the perfect kind of device of that.
就是那种感觉，有什么东西，一种幻想，像幻想一样破灭了，然后你无法复原，我们一直在寻找完美的视觉表现方式。
And I really like that, that sound effect and that's sort of the feeling of that's the moment.
我真的很喜欢那个音效，那正是那种感觉，就是那个瞬间。
There's no turning back.
没有回头路了。
Yeah.
对。
You can't put that toothpaste back in the tube.
覆水难收。
Barney's metaphor was a car, right?
巴尼的比喻是一辆车，对吧？
It was you're driving, and there's a blind spot in the car.
意思是你在开车，车上有个盲区。
There's just a blind spot towards this person, and it feels like a real thing.
对这个人就是有一种盲区，而且感觉很真实。
I definitely feel like it's real.
我绝对觉得这很真实。
I think another good hemiumism besides many mysteries is legitimately interesting, juicy debates.
我觉得另一个好用的委婉说法——除了各种谜团外——是真正有趣、有料的辩论。
This is a philosophical debate, right?
这是一个哲学辩论，对吧？
Totally.
完全是。
Do you say the thing, when do you say the thing, when does it pass the point, when you can say the thing, what if you say the thing they break up and they go back together, all of this is an ethic, this is a study in ethics.
你什么时候该说出来，什么时候该说，什么时候错过了说出来的时机，如果你说出来之后他们分手了又复合了会怎样，所有这些都是伦理学，这是一项伦理学研究。
It really, I don't know whether the university class on how I met your mother could do a juicy seminar in this one.
真的，我不知道关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》的大学课程能不能在这集里开个精彩的研讨会。
Yeah.
对。
And I love how everyone just turns on each other from just everyone's flaws.
而且我喜欢大家如何仅仅因为彼此的缺点而反目成仇。
And it becomes this study in acceptance versus honesty or saying something versus not saying something.
这演变成了一场关于接纳与诚实，或者说直言不讳与缄口不言的研究。
It starts to, in fact, it's almost like this contagion.
它开始，事实上，这几乎就像是一种传染病。
It's almost like an outbreak story.
这几乎就像是一个疫情爆发的故事。
That's like slowly the idea of this glass breaking disease starts like infiltrating the group and just the way everyone turns on each other is really funny.
就像“玻璃碎裂”这种病的想法开始慢慢渗透进这个群体，大家互相针对的方式真的太搞笑了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It's a good gang episode.
这是一集很棒的群戏。
Like the whole gang is- It is a good gang episode, everyone is in the same story.
就像整个死党——这确实是一集很棒的群戏，每个人都在同一个故事里。
Yeah.
对。
Was that fun?
那很有趣吗？
Do you like an episode?
你喜欢拍这样的一集吗？
Do you like acting in an episode like that where it's, well, it's great that it started with Ted.
比如从泰德开始这很棒。
It's great that Ted was the mystery.
泰德成为谜团这很棒。
But then when everyone starts turning on each other, it's there was a good energy.
但后来当大家开始互相针对时，有一种很好的能量。
It was very entertaining to watch.
看的时候非常有趣。
And the flashbacks kind of filling in the lore, as I say, like those were super fun.
而且那些填充背景设定的闪回，正如我所说，那些超级有趣。
Those were fun.
那些很有趣。
Did you, so I'm curious like writer's room, like that's a great writer's room prompt, like what's annoying about each of these people?
你当时——所以我很好奇编剧室是怎么运作的，比如这是一个很棒的编剧室灵感，每个人身上都有什么烦人的地方？
And I think you had established Marshall the singer, right?
我想你们当时已经塑造了爱唱歌的马歇尔，对吧？
Yes, that felt very natural because we were really just calling out something that was already there.
是的，那感觉非常自然，因为我们只是在指出原本就存在的东西。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
His singing was at least in season one was established like he was just by himself, kind of amusing himself, but it was funny to open it up, like he's actually doing it around them the whole time.
他的歌声至少在第一季里就已经确立了，他就像是独自一人，自娱自乐，但把它公开会很有趣，就好像他其实一直都在他们面前这么做。
I think Ted, like by season three, you guys were very much into Ted, the intellect, Ted, the kind of snooty, you know, as neat or whatever.
我觉得泰德，到了第三季左右，你们非常喜欢塑造泰德知识分子的一面，那种有点自命不凡的泰德，你知道，文青什么的。
So I think you were leaning into that.
所以我认为你们在往那个方向倾斜。
You know what's so funny?
你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？
I was, I always felt a little bit, it's so weird cause I'm watching this shit, here, listen, this is a shout out to my mother-in-law.
我以前，我总是觉得有点——这太奇怪了，因为我在看这个狗屎，听着，这是向我岳母致敬。
My mother-in-law doesn't like swearing.
我岳母不喜欢说脏话。
and whenever I say.
每当我说话的时候。
You hear her voice in your head?
你脑海里会浮现她的声音？
Because you say.
因为你说。
I hear her, I hear her, she listens to this show.
我能听到她，我能听到她，她会收听这个节目。
Yeah.
对。
And I hear her thinking, I wish you wouldn't.
我能听到她在想，我希望你别这样。
She doesn't even sound like that.
她听起来才不那样呢。
I wish you wouldn't.
我希望你别这样。
Let's hate me that.
别那样讨厌我。
That's not what her voice sounds like.
她的声音才不是那样的。
Sorry, Vivian.
抱歉，薇薇安。
Whenever I think about, whenever I would think about, or whenever I, you handed us the stuff, the TED as kind of intellectual snob, I knew it worked because it got huge laughs from, you know, the table reads and the crew.
每当我想起，每当我想到，或者每当你们把剧本交给我们，把泰德塑造成那种知识分子势利小人时，我知道这行得通，因为读剧本时和剧组人员都发出了巨大的笑声。
And I knew I was doing it well.
我知道我演得很好。
but there was a part of me that felt a little bit, and I think it was because when I had talked about this, but when I would recommend a book on Twitter, people would be like, oh, you're just like, Ted, like it may feel like I couldn't be my own self who's actually curious about philosophy and theology and literature and love that stuff.
但我的内心深处感到有点，我想这是因为当我谈论过这个时，当我以前在推特上推荐一本书时，人们会说，哦，你太像泰德了。这让我觉得我无法做真实的自己——一个真正对哲学、神学和文学充满好奇并热爱这些东西的人。
And I hope not in an annoying way.
我希望我的表现方式不是那种讨人厌的。
I just, I went to college, I loved literature, I love reading and talking about things that we love talking about those things.
我只是上过大学，我热爱文学，我喜欢阅读和谈论我们热爱的话题。
We do, I mean, it's kind of who we are, it's kind of why we do what we do.
我们确实如此，我是说，这正是我们的天性，这也是我们做这一行的原因。
Right, but I felt like you guys, and again, this is just what we got, we're talking about on this show, you took something about me that I value as a virtue, and you held it up for mockery, and it made me feel like you guys- Are we still having dinner later?
对，但我觉得你们——再说一次，这只是我们的感受，我们在节目里讨论过——你们把我身上一个我认为是美德的特点拿出来供人嘲弄，这让我觉得你们——我们待会儿还要一起吃晚饭吗？
Is this you canceling dinner?
你这是在取消晚饭吗？
We're gonna talk about this, I'm gonna say how I really feel in general.
我们要谈谈这个，我要说说我的真实感受。
No, but it made me feel like these things that I valued about myself were then suddenly held up from Ocarina, and then when I was myself in the real world, it was self-conscious.
不，但这让我觉得我引以为傲的这些特质突然成了嘲笑的对象，以至于后来当我在现实生活中做自己时，我都开始感到不自然了。
Yeah, people were like, you're just like that and going intellectual guy, because you read books.
对，人们会觉得，因为你读书，所以你就像那个自以为是的知识分子。
You like words, you know?
你喜欢掉书袋，对吧？
And it is unfair, and I am sorry about that, because that is a mind-fuck what you just described, and I'm like you, I'm the same way.
这确实很不公平，对此我感到很抱歉，因为你刚才描述的这种心理战太折磨人了，我和你一样，我也是这样的人。
I'm like, and Carter's like that too.
我觉得，卡特也是这样。
No, and Carter was legitimately reading, like Teddy Roosevelt biography.
不，卡特当时确实在认真阅读，比如西奥多·罗斯福的传记。
Yeah, 100%.
对，百分之百。
I knew that you guys were like me and were kind of me, but then here's the thing, here's the kicker.
我知道你们和我很像，某种程度上就是我，但问题是，这就是妙处所在。
That's how I felt 18 years ago.
那是18年前我的感受。
But when I watch it now, it just makes me laugh.
但现在我再看，它只会让我发笑。
It's funny.
这很有趣。
No, that's the thing.
不，关键就在这里。
It's funny.
这很有趣。
这很好笑。
And it's not as annoying as I remember it being, it's charming, it's like, here's the thing, Ted is a dad before he's a dad.
而且它没有我记忆中那么烦人，它很有魅力，就像是，这么说吧，泰德在当爹之前就已经是个爹了。
That's a huge part of his pre-dad.
这是他“准老爸”阶段的重要组成部分。
He's pre-datic.
他有着准老爸的特质。
It's, and I love that we leaned into that.
而且我很高兴我们顺应了这一点。
I don't even know if we knew at first we're doing that.
我甚至不知道我们一开始是否知道我们在这样做。
I think we sort of evolved that.
我觉得我们是顺其自然地发展出了这一点。
Like that's a way that Ted is funny.
就好像这是泰德搞笑的一种方式。
He wants to make dad jokes.
他总是想讲老爸冷笑话。
He wants to give recommendations.
他总是想给出各种建议。
He wants to like solve problems, pros and cons lists.
他总是想解决问题，列出利弊清单。
And it's kind of what's great about Ted because when Ted has to be the champion of an episode, his championness comes from that intellect and that philosophical curiosity and all of those great things.
这正是泰德最棒的地方，因为当泰德必须成为一集的主角时，他的领导力来自于他的才智、哲学好奇心以及所有这些极好的特质。
And then when we need him to be the buffooned in a joke, or because he's sort of doing something silly, we would use the sort of shadow side of that and sort of douche him out along those lines a little bit to make that the joke.
而当我们需要他在笑话里扮演滑稽角色，或者因为他做出了一些傻事时，我们就会利用那些特质的阴暗面，把他的这些特点稍微放大一点，以此来制造笑料。
And sort of it's weak to weak that would change.
而且这种设定每周都在变化。
It's sort of unfair because the superpower became the sort of flaw that it's a superpower again the next week.
这有点不公平，因为超能力在一周后又变成了一种缺点，而到了下周又成了超能力。
Well, it's the same thing you guys did.
嗯，这跟你们做的事是一样的。
My gripe about drum roll please in the episode following is like in one episode, he's lionized for being the romantic hero.
我（敲鼓请注意）对接下来那一集的抱怨是，在一集里，他因为是个浪漫英雄而被奉为偶像。
And the next one, he's completely made fun of for it, for his romanticism.
而在下一集里，他却因为这种浪漫主义而被彻底嘲笑。
So cheesy and insufferable, which in a way that was so over the top, and those are tough to latch back to back.
太老套、太令人难以忍受了，而且那种夸张的程度，要把这两者连在一起真的很难。
It's like, ooh boy, that is a whiplash inducing term.
就好像，天哪，那真是一个让人备受打击的急转弯。
That's what it felt like being inside it.
身处其中时就是这种感觉。
I was like, what is, I called a special meeting with you in Carter to discuss it.
当时我想，这算什么，我还专门和你还有卡特开了个会来讨论这事。
Yeah, and it's true, you have to hit the right tone, you have to think long term, you have to think about how people are gonna binge the show.
是的，确实如此，你必须把握好基调，你必须长远考虑，你必须考虑人们会怎么一口气刷完整部剧。
And it's a hard balance to strike, it really is.
要掌握好这个平衡很难，真的很难。
But I do find when I watch it now, I'm mostly like, this is harmless fun.
但我现在看的时候发现，我大多数时候觉得：这不过是无伤大雅的乐子。
Yes.
没错。
And the only thing though that I felt was like, I worry, it's like, there's an anti-intellectual strain of American comedy.
不过唯一让我觉得担心的是，美国喜剧里似乎有一种反智的倾向。
Oh yes.
哦，是的。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吧？
Like, it really is like a kind of, you know, the college boy is not well regarded in the annals of American comedy.
就像，这真的有点，你知道的，在美国喜剧的悠久历史中，书呆子大学生通常没什么好名声。
And, you know, I did go to college and I do love books and anyone who follows me, you know, what I make and write and gravitate to, like, it's stuff that I just, I find really fascinating, but I also long for depth.
而且，你知道的，我确实上过大学，我也确实热爱书籍，任何关注我的人，都知道我创作、书写以及偏爱的内容，都是那些我真心觉得极其迷人、同时也让我渴望深度的事物。
And so I was trying in my own life to value this stuff and hold it up and then I would go into work and I felt like it was, you know, you know what I mean?
所以我一直在自己的生活中努力重视这些东西并推崇它们，然后我去上班时，又觉得这——你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我懂。
I mean, it's such an interesting like, it's interesting to hear that all these years later and how you felt then and how you look at it now.
我的意思是，多年后的今天听到这些，听到你当时的感受以及你现在如何看待它，真的是一件很有趣的事。
It's such a unique circumstance to play this character for nine years.
连续九年扮演这样一个角色，真是一种独特的经历。
And like, what other format makes a character have to do as many different things where one week he is the romantic lead and the next week he's like the silly buffoon because of the same character traits.
而且，还有什么其他形式能让一个角色去做这么多截然不同的事情：这一周他是浪漫男主角，而下一周，仅仅因为相同的性格特征，他又变成了那个傻里傻气的丑角。
I know and I have great sympathy for, I have great sympathy for where you guys were in terms of needing to vary things up, needing to change the levels and turn the knobs of all these characters week to week.
我知道，我非常理解，我非常理解你们当时为了让内容多样化、需要在每周的节目中调整所有这些角色的层级和设定时所处的难处。
I mean, you guys were doing an enormous amount and brilliantly, Siegel and I used to talk about, because we wrote our own things and we said, could we write how I made it?
我是说，你们当时付出了巨大的努力，而且完成得极其出色。西格尔和我过去常常讨论，因为我们也写自己的东西，我们当时说：“我们能写出《老爸老妈浪漫史》吗？”
Mother and both of us agreed, we could not.
我们俩一致认为，我们写不出来。
We didn't have the brains for it, the different kind of brain.
我们没有那个头脑，那是完全不同的一种头脑。
Well, we were figuring it out.
嗯，我们当时也是在摸索中前进。
That moment you just talked about it in season one, we were figuring out, but it can't he can't be a different character the next Monday it has to be there has to be some consistency right and I think you that's something you only figure out by doing it and by figuring it out week to week I guess them I guess I felt in season one his most pronounced trait was this kind of like impetuous romanticism yes but as the show went on this intellectual snobbery started to develop right and I think I felt because I did crossword puzzles and was bringing and David Foster Wallace books to read in between takes.
你刚才谈到第一季时的那个时刻，我们确实在摸索，但他不能在下一个周一变成一个完全不同的人，角色必须具备连贯性，对吧？我想这是只有通过不断实践、通过每周摸索才能明白的道理。我想，在第一季里，我觉得他最显著的特征就是这种冲动的浪漫主义，没错；但随着剧集的发展，这种知识分子的清高开始显露出来，对吧？我想，可能是因为我在拍戏间隙做填字游戏，还带着大卫·福斯特·华莱士的书在读。
I felt that you guys were studying me and making fun of me.
我觉得你们当时在观察我、在拿我取笑。
We're making fun of ourselves.
我们是在拿自己取笑。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
But it was really, I don't know, I was very thin-skinned about it.
但当时真的……怎么说呢，我对这事极其敏感。
But like I said, I watch it now and I hear Jordana laugh at these things and I think like, oh, this wasn't personal.
但就像我说的，我现在看这部剧，听到佐丹娜（Jordana）对这些情节发出笑声，我就觉得：哦，这根本不是针对个人的。
I took everything personally back then.
我当年把什么事都当成是针对我个人。
But that's the value of looking back at it now.
但这就是回过头来看待它的价值所在。
That's the value of literally what we're doing this very moment.
这就是我们此时此刻正在做的事情的价值所在。
And you're right, because it's just funny now.
你说得对，因为现在看起来只觉得好笑。
I'm watching the episode with Rebecca.
我正在看有丽贝卡（Rebecca）的那一集。
One of the biggest laughs of the whole episode was when their post-coital and Ted corrects her literally as a figuratively.
整集里最大的笑点之一，就是他们刚过完性生活，泰德就字面意义上纠正了她说的“可以说是”还是“比喻上是”的用词。
Like right after he clearly had great sex, but he still just got to be like, well, let's get this right.
就像他明明刚经历了极好的性爱，却还是忍不住说：“嗯，咱们得把话说准确点。”
With the heavy breathing still in, yeah.
而且当时粗重的喘息声都还没消呢，对。
It's just very funny.
这真的太搞笑了。
It's like he's a corrector.
感觉他就是个爱纠错的人。
He has, he wants, he likes to be precise.
他这人就这样，他追求完美，喜欢精确。
He's an architect.
他是个建筑师。
He likes every detail to be in its place.
他喜欢把每一个细节都安排在对的位置上。
You have to be pretty specific as an architect.
作为一名建筑师，你必须得非常严谨才行。
I don't know why when I watch it now.
我不知道为什么我现在看它的时候。
I just find it pretty charming.
我只觉得它相当迷人。
and actually like harmless.
而且实际上还挺无伤大雅的。
It's great.
太棒了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It's just, do we all have, you can like, I used to take every, it's the same, every little thing.
这只是，我们是不是都有，你可以，我以前会把每一个，都一样，每一个小细节。
I didn't watch the show for so many years before this podcast, because I was afraid I would overanalyze it and be like, that joke could have been better.
在这个播客开始前的很多年里，我一直没敢看这部剧，因为我怕自己会过度分析，然后觉得，那个笑话其实可以写得更好。
The internet is right when they say this thing sucked.
网上说这玩意儿烂透了的时候，他们是对的。
I remember somebody hated this one or whatever it is.
我记得有人讨厌这一集或者诸如此类的东西。
And then, you know, you just watch it and you experience it.
然后，你知道，你就只是看着它，去体验它。
And you are a different person watching it right now than you were making it then.
现在的你，和当年制作它时的你，在看它时已经是不同的人了。
And it's a great feeling.
这种感觉真的很棒。
I'm loving rewatching it because of that.
正因如此，我很享受重温它的过程。
It's kind of the whole, you know, it is like the whole point of what we're doing.
这有点像是整个，你知道的，这就好比是我们所做事情的全部意义所在。
Like we're watching, we're revisiting a classic that we had a hand in bringing to life and we're changed and it has changed in a weird way.
就像我们在看，我们在重温一部我们曾亲手让它诞生的经典，我们变了，而且它也以一种奇妙的方式改变了。
It has changed and we're different people.
它变了，我们也都成了不同的人。
And I really, now I can see that Ted was a wannabe dad and he was like, he has all of those traits.
我真的，现在我能看出泰德是个想当爸爸的人，他身上有那种特质，他具备所有这些特征。
It's actually quite well mapped out that he needs, he belongs, he should be those two kids dad.
其实这规划得挺合理的，他需要，他属于，他本来就该是那两个孩子的爸爸。
He should, they're on the couch listening to his wisdom.
他本该如此，孩子们正坐在沙发上听他讲大道理。
This is what he wanted.
这正是他想要的。
He wanted to be able to impart his wisdom to some people.
他希望能向别人传授他的人生经验。
He started doing it to his contemporary age trends in their late twenties.
他一开始是对自己同龄的、快三十岁的朋友们这么做的。
And sometimes he'd be like, shut the fuck up, dad.
有时他们会说，闭上你的臭嘴吧，老爸。
You're not really a dad.
你根本不是个爸爸。
And sometimes they had to be, but that was his deeper one.
有时他们不得不接受，但这才是他更深层的愿望。
But he also went from, he goes from Robin and Barney rolling their eyes at him to his kids rolling their eyes at him.
但他也从一开始罗宾和巴尼对他的翻白眼，变成了后来的孩子们对他的翻白眼。
No, which is by the way, the circle of life.
不，顺便说一句，这就是生命的轮回。
That's what that's my kids do, that's me all the time.
就是这样，我孩子们也这样，我一直都这样。
Yeah.
对。
So what were the other, so lilies, where did lilies?
那其他的呢，莉莉的，莉莉的什么？
Martial songs, lilies, loud chewing.
马修的歌，莉莉的，大声咀嚼。
I feel like that might have been somebody in the writer's room being like, I don't even know, and this isn't me trying to forget who not wanting to say the name, but I feel like it's some, or maybe it was some other writer's room, because when you sit there eating around each other for 10 years on a TV show, all you do is eat.
我觉得那可能是编剧室里的某个人在想，我甚至不知道，我不是想故意忘掉或者不想说出那个名字，但我感觉是某个人，或者可能是别的编剧室，因为当你们在一档电视剧里围坐在一起吃东西吃了10年，你们唯一在做的事就是吃。
You're just sitting there eating, and I feel like there were just stories about how some people just, it's really resonant when one person needs two people can eat the same thing and somehow some different acoustics are happening.
你们就坐在那儿吃，我觉得总会有一些关于某些人的故事，真的很有共鸣——当一个人，两个人吃一样的东西，却不知为何会产生不同的声音效果时。
I think I might have come from like that because you are basically eating around each other the entire time.
我觉得我可能就是从那来的，因为你们基本上从头到尾都在互相旁边吃东西。
It's also a classic kind of like you're around someone so long.
这也是一种典型的情况，就像你和某个人待得太久了。
It's like a classic like how would I never notice that?
这就好比经典的那种“我怎么从来没注意到过？”。
It's the frog in the boiling water.
这就叫温水煮青蛙。
You just don't know and Marshall's the frog.
你根本察觉不到，而马修就是那只青蛙。
He doesn't know that there's this crazy boiling water.
他根本不知道这水正在疯狂地烧开。
And but you know what?
但你知道吗？
That made me laugh so fucking hard.
那把我笑得他妈的半死。
Just because it's so stupid.
就因为它太蠢了。
the incredibly boosted.
音效被放得超级大。
I remember doing the sound mix of that episode and being like louder, louder and the sound mix people don't like doing wrong sounding sound effects.
我记得在做那一集的混音时，一直在要求声音再大点、再大点，混音师其实不太喜欢做听起来不太正常的音效。
You have to like really coax them out to the edge.
你必须得连哄带骗，把他们逼到边缘。
And like, I just want you to know, whatever you think is loud enough, it's gonna be 40% louder than that.
就像是，我只想让你知道，不管你觉得多大声才够，最后出来的效果都要比那再响40%。
Yes, yes.
对，对。
You have to really like inch them up to the cliff.
你必须得一点点把他们逼到悬崖边上。
Well, to sell those jokes, I mean, again, it's the kind of thing of like, how will people describe this chewing go?
嗯，为了卖出那些笑点，我是说，还是那句话，这就好比人们会怎么形容这个咀嚼声呢？
you know, like how many different ways and Stephen Lloyd wrote some great that is very like you get Stephen Lloyd that prompt and he will just fucking run with it.
你知道的，会有多少种不同的方式，斯蒂芬·劳埃德写了一些很棒的桥段，非常符合你给斯蒂芬·劳埃德这种命题，他绝对能发挥得淋漓尽致。
And I was like, where did you was it?
当时我就问，你是在哪儿买的？是吗？
Where did you buy that cereal?
你到底在哪儿买的那个麦片？
Like, was it a home depot or something?
就像是在家得宝（Home Depot）还是什么地方买的？
And then all the thing of like a pair of cufflinks being sucked up into a vacuum, like there were those beaut poetic turns of phrase.
然后还有那种，比如一副袖扣被吸进真空吸尘器里的桥段，那些诗意的遣词造句真的很美妙。
What was the dinosaur role?
恐龙那个梗是什么？
Wasn't there a T-rex one?
不是有个霸王龙的吗？
Yeah, yeah, it was like you like he sounded like Jurassic Park or whatever.
对，对，就好像听起来像《侏罗纪公园》什么的。
Like, it was so elegantly written over.
而且写得真的非常优雅。
I'm butchering them all, but that was very Stephen Lloyd wheelhouse.
我全给说砸了，但这绝对是斯蒂芬·劳埃德（Stephen Lloyd）擅长的风格。
I also loved Hannegan's face of like nothing's, we're just, nothing's the problem.
我也很喜欢汉尼根（Hannegan）那种若无其事的表情，就好像什么事都没有，我们只是，什么都不是问题。
Like we're all just eating, like her obliviousness too.
就好像我们都在吃东西，还有她那种浑然不知的样子。
And Marshall walking down, also oblivious and happy.
马歇尔走过来时也同样毫不知情、高高兴兴的。
There's a shot of the three of you walking down the street and Ted is like, what the fuck is she doing with her mouth?
有一个镜头是你们三个在街上走，泰德（Ted）的表情好像在说，她嘴里到底在瞎比划什么鬼？
And Marshall's like, boop, boop, boop, that is so stupid.
马歇尔则说，嘟，嘟，嘟，这太蠢了。
You know, it's so funny is, I mean, Seagull, anytime Seagull had to sing, I think those were all Jason Seagull originals, right?
你知道最搞笑的是，我是说，席格尔（Seagull），每当席格尔得唱歌时，我想那些都是杰森·席格尔（Jason Seagull）自己原创的吧？
Did you guys?
你们是这样的吗？
We would just give him words and he would just do it.
我们只会给他几个词，然后他就直接开唱了。
And he just, Jason Seagull is somebody who he understands the mission.
而且他，杰森·席格尔就是那种深谙任务核心的人。
He's just that guy, like, I got it.
他就是那种人，心领神会。
And I think he came up with all the like melodies of all of that stuff.
我觉得所有那些乱七八糟的旋律都是他自己想出来的。
But also something that is always going to be in my head is and a roll of courses, the roll of courses.
但还有一件事会一直在我的脑子里挥之不去，那就是“一卷课程”，就是那个课程的卷轴。
Roll of course, yes, the road kind of.
是课程的卷轴，对，算是道路那种吧。
So Lillie, I mean, Robins was literally figuratively, right?
所以莉莉，我是说，罗宾（Robins）的口头禅是字面上的还是象征意义上的，对吧？
Yes.
对的。
And Barney's was, he had like five of them.
而巴尼的则是，他大概有五种之多。
Yeah, but he had a bunch that were just his traits.
对，但他有一堆口头禅纯粹是代表他个人特质的。
But his traits, but he just like owned them as like, he was the least hurt.
但他的那些特质，他只是把它们当成理所当然，就好像，他是最不受伤害的那个。
He didn't even know what people were talking about.
他甚至不知道别人在说什么。
Like, what do you mean?
就好像，你们在说什么？
I'm just awesome.
我就是这么牛。
Yeah, he's no zero self-awareness and that fits.
对，他完全没有自我意识，这很符合他人设。
Yeah.
对。
And that was, yeah, and yeah, Robins was the overuse of literally, I guess, and basically that was her main, was there another one for Robin that came out, or was that it?
而且，对，罗宾的毛病就是过度使用“literally（简直/字面上）”这个词，我猜还有“basically（基本上）”，这就是她的主要毛病，罗宾还有别的吗，还是就这些？
That might have been the only one.
那可能就是唯一的一个了。
I mean, Ted could have maybe talked about her love of gun culture.
我是说，泰德或许可以拿她对枪支文化的喜爱说事。
That could have been the thing.
那倒也可能是一个槽点。
Or her intimacy avoidance.
或者她对亲密关系的逃避。
I mean, there were many things that could have, but these were, I think that, I think the point of this is these are innocuous on some level.
我是说，能吐槽的点有很多，但这些，我觉得重点在于，这些在某种程度上都是无伤大雅的。
These are completely innocuous.
这些完全是无害的。
These are not character-assassinating things.
这些并不是那种会毁掉一个人人设的事情。
They're not like you're actually cruel to people or you have a criminal, you know, sociopathic.
它们不像是什么你对别人真的很残酷，或者你有什么犯罪倾向、反社会人格之类。
It's just who they are.
这只是他们原本的样子。
这只是他们本来的面目。
And so it begins, that's why it's a deeper debate.
所以这就开始了，这就是为什么这是一个更深层次的辩论。
It's like, well, you have to love this about me.
就好像，好吧，你必须爱我身上的这一面。
If you're going to love me romantically or as a friend, you're probably just going to have to like that I make up these songs.
如果你想和我谈恋爱或者做朋友，你大概只能接受我总是编这些乱七八糟的歌。
Like, I should be with the person who likes my little songs.
就像，我应该和那个喜欢听我瞎编小曲儿的人在一起。
But isn't it funny, like with a dear friend or a spouse, like one day a thing can be completely charming and delightful.
但你不觉得很搞笑吗，对于一个挚友或伴侣来说，有时一件事情可能完全迷人又讨喜。
And if you're just a little like woke up on the wrong side of the bed, it's just like, it's unbearable.
可如果你刚好有点起床气，状态不对，就会觉得这简直让人无法忍受。
And it's you know that it's you.
而且你自己心里也清楚问题出在你身上。
Yeah.
对。
I'm very relieved that Jordana is out on a walk right now, by the way.
顺便说一句，我很庆幸乔丹娜（Jordana）现在出门散步去了。
She just left.
她刚刚才离开。
That's why we can talk about this stuff.
这就是为什么我们可以聊这些东西。
Okay, good.
好吧，那就好。
Thank God.
谢天谢地。
Okay, let it rip.
好啦，放开了聊吧。
Just let it rip.
尽管畅所欲言吧。
This is the same space.
这就是这样一个空间。
So there's this article that in 2016, I think, in the New York Times, it was the number one most read and emailed article in the whole paper for the whole year.
是这样的，2016年的时候，我记得《纽约时报》刊登过一篇文章，那是那一整年里整份报纸阅读量和被转发邮件次数最高的第一名。
And it's by this Swiss philosopher named Alain de Bataan, who's really interesting and worth checking out.
作者是一位名叫阿兰·德波顿（Alain de Bataan）的瑞士哲学家，他真的非常有趣，很值得去了解一下。
He has TED talks.
他做过TED演讲。
He's a really fascinating guy.
他真的是个很迷人的人。
But the article, the headline is, why you will marry the wrong person.
但那篇文章的标题是：为什么你会娶（嫁）错人。
And Alec will put this in the show notes, yeah?
亚历克（Alec）会把这个放进节目简介里吧？
Yeah.
会的。
It's called why you will marry the wrong person.
文章标题就叫“为什么你会娶错人”。
Wait, Craig, just read the first...
等等，克雷格，直接读一下前……
A couple paragraphs a year ago.
前几年写的几个段落。
Yeah, I just opened it up.
对，我刚刚把它打开了。
Okay, I'm gonna read the opening.
好的，我要读一下开头。
It's great.
写得太棒了。
This is a fascinating, yeah.
这是一个很迷人的，对。
Sorry, I had to write why you will marry the wrong person.
抱歉，我得写下“为什么你会娶错人”。
It's one of the things we are most afraid might happen to us.
这是我们最害怕发生在自己身上的事情之一。
We go to great lengths to avoid it, and yet we do it all the same.
我们竭尽全力去避免它，然而我们最终还是难逃宿命。
We marry the wrong person.
我们娶（嫁）错了人。
Partly it's because we have a bewildering array of problems that emerge when we try to get close to others.
部分原因在于，当我们试图与他人亲近时，会涌现出一系列令人眼花缭乱的问题。
We seem normal only to those who don't know us very well.
我们只有在那些不太了解我们的人面前，才显得很正常。
You know, why is there more self-war society than our own?
你知道的，为什么社会上没有比我们自己更多的自我反省呢？
A standard question on any early dinner date would be, and how are you crazy?
在任何早期的约会晚餐上，一个标准的提问会是：“嘿，你都有哪些疯狂的毛病？”
Perhaps we have a latent tendency to get furious when someone disagrees with us, or can relax only when we're working.
也许我们有一种潜在的倾向：当别人不同意我们的看法时就会勃然大怒，或者只有在工作时才能放松下来。
Perhaps we're tricky about intimacy after sex, or clam up in response to humiliation.
也许我们在发生性关系后对亲密接触感到棘手，或者在面对羞辱时闭口不言。
Nobody's perfect.
人无完人。
The problem is that before marriage, we rarely delve into our complexities.
问题在于，在结婚之前，我们很少深入探讨彼此复杂的内心。
It goes on from there, which is great.
后面还有很多，都写得很好。
Yeah, really worth reading.
对，真的很值得一读。
But I thought...
但我觉得……
It's brilliant.
太精彩了。
Really, it really hits on something in this episode.
真的，它真的戳中了这一集里的某些核心。
I mean, this is a good story.
我是说，这是一个很好的观点。
One of the privileges of being on our own is therefore the sincere impression that we are really quite easy to live with.
单身带来的特权之一，就是让我们产生一种真诚的错觉，觉得自己其实是一个非常好相处的人。
It's exactly, I mean, it's really on topic of this episode.
确实如此，我是说，这完全切中了这一集的主题。
So I think that I wanted to talk about this because there is a thing where dating, like the difference between dating and marriage is almost hilarious.
所以我想聊这个，是因为存在这样一种现象：恋爱，恋爱和婚姻的区别简直滑稽可笑。
Like how we were dating to figure out if we wanna marry someone, these are not, these are in different universes, you know?
比如我们谈恋爱是为了弄清楚我们是否想和某人结婚，而这两者根本不在同一个世界里，你知道吗？
I think there's a great Chris Rockline about how like, you're not actually dating someone, the person you're dating their representative or ambassador, like they send out an ambassador on behalf of themselves to like make it all look kind of good.
我觉得克里斯·罗克（Chris Rock）有一个很棒的段落，大意是说你其实并不是在和某人约会，你在约会的是他们的代表或大使，他们会派出一个代表来代表自己，好让一切看起来都挺美好的。
That's brilliant.
这太绝了。
And there's something like, I don't know, there's something, I think this is both a pro and a con about marriage and it's the same thing, which is that you will see a lot of yourself.
而且还有一种感觉，我不知道，我觉得关于婚姻既有优点也有缺点，而且指向的都是同一件事，那就是你会从（伴侣身上）看到大量自己的影子。
you will see a lot of yourself from, you know, like if you're living alone and you're lying on the couch and scrolling on the phone for four hours, no one's there to look at you and be like, you've been on the couch a long time scrolling on your phone, you know, either just the look, or just their presence makes you realize that you're doing it.
你会看到很多自己的行为，你知道的，比如如果你独自生活，躺在沙发上刷了四个小时手机，没有人会站在那里看着你说：“你在沙发上刷手机已经很久了，你知道吗”，无论是仅仅一个眼神，还是仅仅他们的存在，都会让你意识到自己正在这么做。
You can, there's so much delusion that's available to you if you're not living with someone, whether it's roommates or a spouse, you know.
如果你不和别人住在一起——不管是室友还是配偶，你就会陷入极其严重的自欺欺人之中。
And I just think it's such a funny thing to encounter your own insanity, vis-a-vis another person.
我只是觉得，在另一个人身上直面自己的疯狂，是一件非常搞笑的事。
And it feels like even the happiest marriages contain this level of like, one, it's like, you see things about the other person, but also like, you know that they're seeing things about you, that you have deluded yourself into thinking are not that big a deal, but then you're like, yeah, this is actually pretty annoying, this thing I do.
感觉哪怕是最幸福的婚姻，也包含着这样一种层面：一方面，你会看到对方身上的种种问题；但另一方面，你也知道他们正在看着你身上的问题——那些你曾自欺欺人觉得“没什么大不了”的问题，然后你会突然意识到：“没错，我做这事其实挺讨人嫌的。”
Accepting that you're also annoying and that however annoying you are, they're also going to be annoyed by you.
接受你自己也很讨厌的事实，并且无论你多么令人厌烦，他们也同样会对你感到厌烦。
And I liked in this article, it was pro-pessimism, this article, in a weird way to do.
而且我很喜欢这篇文章，用一种很奇特的方式，它居然是支持悲观主义的。
That was such a surprising choice.
这真是一个令人惊喜的选择。
I'm trying to find that part, he says, the philosophy of pessimism offers a solution to a lot of distress and agitation around marriage.
我正在找那部分，他说，悲观主义的哲学为围绕婚姻的许多痛苦和焦虑提供了一种解决方案。
It might sound odd, but pessimism relieves the excessive imaginative pressure that our romantic culture places upon marriage, The failure of one particular partner to save us from our grief and melancholy is not an argument against that person and no sign that a union deserves to fail or be upgraded.
这听起来可能有点奇怪，但悲观主义减轻了我们的浪漫文化强加给婚姻的过度的想象压力，某一个特定的伴侣无法将我们从悲伤和忧郁中拯救出来，这不是反对那个人的理由，也不是婚姻注定失败或需要升级的迹象。
It's such an interesting idea of like, just, whoever you wind up with will be flawed and so are you and so don't panic if you realize that.
这是一个非常有趣的观点，就像是，无论你最终和谁在一起，对方都会有缺点，你也是，所以当你意识到这一点时，不要惊慌。
So that's interesting why this episode, maybe Ted should have stuck it out a little longer.
所以这就很有趣了，为什么这一集里，也许泰德应该再坚持一会儿。
He also said something interesting that I don't know if it was in this episode or another episode.
他还说了一些有趣的话，我不知道是在这一集还是在另一集里。
I mean, in this thing or in one of his talks, But he said there's a benefit to getting married later.
我是说，在这段内容里还是在他的某次演讲中，但他说晚婚是有好处的。
Does he say this in there?
他在里面说过这个吗？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
Well, his point is, by the time you get to be older, you know, say, for instance, you get gloomy on Sunday nights.
嗯，他的观点是，等你年纪大一点的时候，比如说，你在周日晚上会感到沮丧。
You get weird on Sundays.
你会在周日变得有点怪异。
If you get married too young and you don't know that about yourself, you might blame your partner for that.
如果你结婚太早，而且你还不了解自己的这一点，你可能会把这怪罪于你的伴侣。
But if you get married a little bit older, you can go, hey, just the heads up, I get weird on Sundays.
但如果你稍微晚一点结婚，你就可以说，嘿，提前打个招呼，我周日的时候会有点怪。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, Sunday nights will be.
你知道，周日晚上会是……
Yeah, here's the user manual.
是的，这是用户手册。
Yes, yes, you know your own kind of user manual and you're less apt to blame the other person and it's funny because Except for Marshall and Lily.
对，对，你知道你自己的那种用户手册，你就不太会去责怪对方了，而且很有趣的是，除了马歇尔和莉莉。
No one is romantically involved with the other person and anyone else, you know Robin and Ted aren't together Barney and Robin aren't yet together.
没有人跟其他人有恋爱关系，还有其他人，你知道罗宾和泰德没有在一起，巴尼和罗宾还没有在一起。
Yeah, this is really Um, I mean there's two levels.
是的，这真的是……我是说有两个层面。
There's you know them trying to warn Ted off this woman, but there's also this this Spider-Man finger pointing meme, where everyone is kind of pointing out the thing about each other.
一方面是他们试图劝泰德离开这个女人，但另一方面也有这种“蜘蛛侠手指互指”的梗，每个人都在指出对方身上的问题。
But also that level of insight into another person, what is kind of annoying, and the courage to be able to tell it is a sign of intimacy.
但同时，那种对另一个人的洞察力，什么地方有点烦人，以及能够说出来的勇气，正是亲密关系的标志。
Right, and I think that's talked about in that article too, it's like that actually is intimacy.
对，而且我觉得那篇文章里也谈到了这一点，就像那其实就是亲密关系。
It's having the courage and the guts to risk that with somebody and to do.
那是拥有和某人冒险的勇气和胆量，并且去这样做。
Well, he says the day your marriage begins the day you wake up and say, what have I done?
嗯，他说，你婚姻开始的那一天，就是你醒来并说：“我都做了些什么？”
What have I done?
“我都做了些什么？”的那一天。
Yeah.
是的。
That's when the hard work of marriage kind of kicks in, right?
那才是婚姻的苦功真正开始的时候，对吧？
Because you're just having to, I think it's less, honestly, about a confrontation with the other and more about confrontation with self.
因为你不得不，老实说，这与其说是与对方的对抗，不如说是与自我的对抗。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
而这个老头，他一定……爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在是广告时间。
End of commercials?
广告结束了吗？
Back to show.
回到节目。
One thing I like bringing it back to the sort of the surprise plot twist in this episode, that marshals, the fact that marshals annoying song trade is the thing that solves the other big mystery in this episode, the other big, the actual stakes of this episode, besides, is dad gonna break up with this woman that we just met.
我喜欢的一点是，把话题拉回到这一集里那个令人意外的情节反转上，马歇尔那令人讨厌的唱歌习惯，竟然成了解开这一集另一个巨大谜团的关键，这一集的另一个悬念，或者说真正的赌注，除了他爸会不会跟这个刚认识的女人分手之外。
The realer stakes in some ways is, is Marshall gonna become a lawyer today?
在某些方面，更现实的赌注是，马歇尔今天能成为一名律师吗？
So you'll find out he passed the bar and his life isn't forever changed by that one piece of information.
所以你会发现他通过了律考，而他的人生并没有因为这一个信息而永远改变。
He's lost the password to log in and find the bar results that just went live.
他弄丢了登录密码，无法查看刚刚公布的律考成绩。
And he's getting all these calls from all his friends.
他不断接到所有朋友的电话。
I'm a lawyer.
我是一名律师了。
And it's been driving him fucking crazy.
这快把他他妈的逼疯了。
And he can't find it.
而他却找不到密码。
And then the fact that his flaw is also the key that solves the puzzle box of this episode.
然后，他的缺点竟然也是解开这一集谜题的钥匙。
I think it's a beautiful idea.
我觉得这是一个绝妙的想法。
It's very deep, it's very, yes, in quotes.
非常深刻，非常，是的，加引号的深刻。
It's also just like a very satisfying, it's so funny, there's two mysteries running, like what is Marshall's password and what's wrong with Ted's new girlfriend?
这也非常令人满足，太搞笑了，有两个谜团在同时进行，一个是马歇尔的密码是什么，另一个是泰德的新女友有什么毛病？
Yes.
是的。
But there's something just satisfying almost in an Agatha Christie type way.
但其中有一种令人满足的感觉，几乎带有一种阿加莎·克里斯蒂式的风格。
It's a mystery.
这是一个谜题。
It's totally a mystery, yes.
这完全是一个谜，是的。
Oh my God, that's the thing.
哦天哪，就是这个。
and that the song unlocks the password and then they all gather round and then just get to celebrate.
而且那首歌解开了密码，然后大家聚在一起，接着就可以庆祝了。
Oh, it's so sweet.
哦，太美好了。
I really loved that.
我真的很喜欢那个。
I loved Apple orchard Banana Cat Dance 8, 6, 6, 3, Rachel Ziegler, you know that act the actress Rachel Ziegler, she's a white side story, huge hymium fan, and she once sent me on like Twitter or something, a video of her singing that song.
我喜欢“苹果园香蕉猫舞8663”，瑞秋·齐格勒，你知道那个女演员瑞秋·齐格勒吗，她演了《西区故事》，是个超级迷恋本剧的粉丝，她曾经在推特还是什么地方发过一个她唱那首歌的视频。
And when I got the video, I went, I forget what episode that was completely forgot.
当我收到那个视频时，我想，我完全忘了那是哪一集了。
What if that was her audition for Steven Spielberg for West Side Story?
万一那是她为史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的《西区故事》试镜呢？
That was her audition for West Side Story.
那确实是她为《西区故事》的试镜。
And that's how she got the role.
她就是靠那个拿到角色的。
But she was, I love that she's such a big fan.
但我很高兴她是个这么大的粉丝。
She also has a video for singing other hymium songs.
她还有一个唱其他本剧歌曲的视频。
It's like very cool that she, but I love that she's not the only fan that loves that one little bit.
她能这样真的很酷，但我喜欢她并不是唯一一个喜欢那个小片段的粉丝。
That one little thing.
就那一小点。
And I think it's because it's so satisfying in this episode.
我想这是因为这在这一集里太让人满足了。
genuinely the solution to the miss.
这真的是谜题的解法。
It really does feel like the Sherlock Holmes has solved the case.
这真的感觉就像福尔摩斯破了案。
The fact that that is the code, the A, B, O, blah, blah, blah, number number, and that is how we get to it.
那个密码居然是A、B、O，巴拉巴拉，数字数字，我们就是这样找到它的。
It's such a great, they're fighting and they're fighting and they're fighting and then they're like completely jubilant one second later.
这太棒了，他们吵啊吵啊吵，然后在一秒钟后变得完全欢欣鼓舞。
And I think that by accepting that flaw and seeing now his flaw has saved the day, I think it's actually making kind of a nice statement that.
我想，通过接受那个缺点，看到他的缺点现在拯救了局势，这其实是在表达一个很美好的观点。
And again, I think that there's something, your ability and your willingness to write flawed characters who know their flawed, who love, you know, I love that quote, we don't love because of, we love in spite of.
再次重申，我觉得这里面有某种东西，你有能力也愿意去描写那些深知自己有缺点、懂得去爱的有缺陷的角色，你知道，我很喜欢那句名言：我们爱不是因为完美，而是尽管有缺点依然去爱。
Yes.
是的。
You know, this is really an example of that.
你知道，这真的是一个例子。
But I think it's kind of, like when we lead with vulnerability, when we lead with our flaws, it does elicit a certain amount of trust.
但我认为，当我们将脆弱展现在前，当我们坦诚自己的缺点时，它确实能换来一定程度的信任。
You know, if someone walks in and they're like, you know, like Alec Baldwin and Glenn Gary Gillan Ross, you're just like, kind of, I gotta get away from this guy.
你知道，如果有人走进来，就像《拜金一族》里的亚历克·鲍德温那样，你就会觉得，有点想离这家伙远点。
Like, I don't care about his watch.
就像，我才不在乎他的手表。
Like he's really, this is not gonna be a good friend of mine.
就像他这个人，绝对不会成为我的好朋友。
You know?
你知道吗？
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
But if someone comes in not in a totally self-disrespecting way, but I always trust people who are alert to their own flaws, it tells me they have, you know, the ability to self-critique their onto themselves there.
但如果有人进来，不是以一种完全自轻自贱的方式，而且我总是信任那些对自己的缺点保持警觉的人，这告诉我他们具备自我审视的能力，他们对自己有着清醒的认知。
You know, it's, it's, you know.
你知道，这很……
I always never shied away from your own flaws, Craig.
你从来没有回避过你自己的缺点，克雷格。
You're pretty up front about them.
你对它们一直挺坦诚的。
I think that's how you connect to people, right?
我想这就是你与人连接的方式，对吧？
It's that is how you connect.
这就是你建立连接的方式。
You're like, this is what's stupid about me.
你会说，这就是我很蠢的地方。
I, therefore, I will accept that about you too.
因此，我也会接受你身上的这一点。
And in the end of this episode, I find it very sweet that all of their flaws are coming out or as they're celebrating Marshall and no one's noticing, because they're just having this great, they realize a landmark moment has happened in Marshall's life.
而在这一集的结尾，我发现非常温馨的是，当他们为马歇尔庆祝时，所有人身上的缺点都在暴露出来，而没有人注意到，因为他们正沉浸在极大的喜悦中，他们意识到马歇尔的人生中发生了一个具有里程碑意义的时刻。
They've all shared it because they love each other.
他们因为彼此相爱而共同分享了这一刻。
Right, and again, when you're in love, when you're in your heart, those things don't- You don't notice them anymore.
对，再次重申，当你陷入爱河时，当你的内心充满爱时，那些事情就不会……你再也注意不到它们了。
At the end of the episode, they go back to not noticing them because something amazing has happened for their friend whom they love.
在这一集的结尾，他们又回到了注意不到这些缺点状态，因为他们深爱的朋友身上发生了一件了不起的事。
You know, a friend of mine who's older, but him and his wife would teach relationship classes and stuff, and they're very brilliant people, but I asked him, this is years ago, and I said, what's the problem, like what's the central problem with most relationships?
你知道，我有一个年纪稍大的朋友，他和他的妻子会教授恋爱课程之类的内容，他们是非常优秀的人，但多年前我问他，我说，问题出在哪里，大多数恋爱关系的核心问题是什么？
And he said, the very thing that draws you to someone, curdles and kind of becomes toxic.
他说，正是那个最初吸引你被某人吸引的特质，最后会变质并变得具有毒性。
So if you, when you're falling in love, it's, oh my God, he's so responsible with money.
所以，当你坠入爱河时，你会想，哦天哪，他对金钱太有责任感了。
And then three years later, he's so cheap, you know?
然后三年后，他变得太吝啬了，你知道吗？
Like, oh, he's so, like he really values home time.
就像，哦，他太……他真的很重视居家时间。
He's such a good, like homebody.
他是个多好的顾家的人啊。
He won't go to a party to save his life.
他打死也不去参加派对。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
These things just become the very thing that drew you becomes a liability, and you just kind of navigate that stuff.
这些特质最终成了曾经吸引你的那个负担，你只需去应付这些事情。
But I think the more alert we are to our own nonsense and our own flaws, the more forgiving we can be of others.
但我认为，我们对自己的荒唐行为和缺点越是保持警觉，我们就越能宽容他人。
I mean, in a way, it's what we were talking about about watching the show again 20 years later and the things we were so sensitive about or so alert to, oh my God, there's gonna be this, I'm gonna, someone doesn't like this or someone's making fun of me or this thing.
我的意思是，从某种程度上说，这就好比我们之前谈过的，20年后重看这部剧，那些我们曾经极度敏感或高度警惕的事情，天啊，会有这个，我会，有人会不喜欢这个，或者有人在取笑我，或者诸如此类的事。
It's really, it really comes out on the fucking wash, right?
随着时间推移，一切真的都会烟消云散，对吧？
It really does over time.
随着时间推移，确实如此。
And you just throw your arms around that younger version of yourself and you go, I see you buddy, I see you, I love you, you're okay.
然后你会张开双臂拥抱那个年轻的自己，对他说，我看见你了，老兄，我看见你了，我爱你，你没事的。
I imagine it's the same like when you're neurotic about parenting and then you're like at their college graduation and you're like, man, we kind of over worried.
我猜这就像你对育儿感到神经质，然后到了他们大学毕业典礼时，你会想，天哪，我们当初真是操心过头了。
Like they did okay, like everything worked out, like you just gotta, yeah.
就像他们表现得挺好，一切都迎刃而解，你只需要，对吧。
So just a couple of things that I thought were so funny and clever in this episode, I loved Robin's line.
所以，有几个我觉得在这集里非常搞笑和聪明的点，我特别喜欢罗宾的那句台词。
She's a keeper, just keeper somewhere.
她是个宝藏，只要把宝藏藏在某个地方。
Oh my God, it's, that's such a funny line.
天啊，这，这台词太搞笑了。
That is like a vaudeville joke.
这就像是一个杂耍喜剧里的笑话。
Totally, totally vaudeville joke, yeah.
完全是，标准的杂耍喜剧笑话，对。
Still good, it is good at those.
依然很棒，她很擅长这种。
Who are the guys who puked and ran out screaming?
那两个呕吐并尖叫着跑出去的家伙是谁？
Oh, it's in the bar, the bar exam?
哦，是在那个酒吧里，在律师资格考试的时候吗？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
I was wondering if those actors have that on their reel.
我在想那些演员的个人作品集里有没有这段。
I know, I'm the guy that ran out screaming.
我懂，我就是那个尖叫着跑出去的家伙。
Like, that was funny.
真的，那太搞笑了。
It was a good screaming run out of it.
他尖叫着跑出去的那一下很棒。
It was very loud.
声音非常大。
Barney's obsession with showing Marshall the video of a dog, putting that up to him.
巴尼执着于给马歇尔看一只狗的视频，把它举到他面前。
And again, he has to be a sociopath.
而且话说回来，他绝对是个反社会人格。
He has to create, he creates a days long back story about, he's gonna, he's got a guy.
他必须创造，他凭空捏造了一个长达数天的背景故事，说他要，他认识一个人。
Yeah.
对。
The government is involved.
政府也牵涉其中。
He has an aria about the- To get him to watch a video of a dog pooping on a baby.
他甚至还发表了一段咏叹调——为了让他看一段狗在婴儿身上拉屎的视频。
And cock-ass banial.
还有金毛寻回犬。
And then golden reliever was gonna be next.
接下来还要放“黄金接盘侠”。
Yeah.
对。
These are all Steven Lloyd 101.
这些全都是史蒂芬·劳埃德式的经典桥段。
Steven Lloyd is just a genius.
史蒂芬·劳埃德简直是个天才。
I love what you guys found.
我喜欢你们发现的这些细节。
Like Robyn, when Robyn tells a joke that doesn't work and won't like take the L.
比如罗宾，当罗宾讲了个不好笑的笑话却又不肯承认失败的时候。
Yeah.
对。
is so funny.
真的太搞笑了。
Ted's imagining of what could be wrong with her is so funny.
泰德想象她身上可能出了什么问题，这也超级搞笑。
Yes, those were very elaborate.
对，那些想象非常细致。
Those were very dark.
那些脑洞都太黑暗了。
Those were all steep.
这全都是史蒂芬的手笔。
Any time you see something very elaborate or neatly worded and supremely dark, that is Stephen Lloyd, that's just like put it.
每当你看到那些极其详尽、措辞工整且极度黑暗的内容，那就是史蒂芬·劳埃德的风格，直接用就行了。
It didn't get rewritten at all.
剧本完全没有被重写过。
You'll notice some many seasons later, the murder house was complimented.
你会发现很多季之后，那个“凶宅”也被称赞过。
The murder house is a Stephen Lloyd.
凶宅就是史蒂芬·劳埃德的创意。
And again, to bring it back to around, I don't want to, I, you have some other tidbits, maybe Josh, but Stephen Lloyd is in the tag and he plays, he plays a deaf character, slightly problematic.
话说回来，绕回正题，我不想，我，你还有其他趣闻吗，乔什？不过史蒂芬·劳埃德在彩蛋里客串了，他演了一个耳聋的角色，稍微有点政治不正确。
Alec, I would say, right?
埃里克，我想可以这么说吧？
We probably should have given that to a deaf actor.
我们当时或许应该把这个角色给一个真正的聋哑演员。
But here we are.
但木已成舟。
It was, it was a long time ago, we're learning.
那是很久以前的事了，我们也在不断学习。
But we, you know, it's his Alfred Hitchcock cameo and the piece of work he, he wrote.
不过我们都知道，这是他版本的希区柯克式客串，演的是他自己写的东西。
So it was, it felt like it was fun to see the writer be in an episode, but also Ted shattering him.
所以看到编剧本人出现在剧集里感觉挺有意思的，但同时也被泰德无情地“粉碎”了。
Ted shattering and ruining her for him.
泰德粉碎了他，也毁了他在他心目中的形象。
And the idea, I had forgotten that we did the very meta weird joke that the shattering glass was in parenthetical as a caption.
而且我想起，我差点忘了我们当时玩了一个非常元叙事、很怪异的梗：作为字幕，玻璃破碎的声音居然是以括号形式出现的。
You didn't actually hear the glass that time, it's a very thinkery joke.
那次你其实并没有听到玻璃碎的声音，这是一个非常需要动脑筋的笑话。
But he, you see it being destroyed, Stephen Lloyd acted that very well, seeing that moment land on his face, whereas he's just ruined for him now too, for Ted, I don't like Ted really meant to do that.
但你可以看到它被毁了，史蒂芬·劳埃德演得非常好，那种看着这一刻打击落在他脸上的表情，而现在他对泰德来说也彻底崩塌了，虽然泰德并不是真的故意要这么做。
I love Barney's story about Lucilla in Rio.
我喜欢巴尼讲的关于里约热内卢的露西拉的故事。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
Yeah.
对。
What does this have to do with Kathy?
这跟凯茜有什么关系？
He's such a sociopath, narcissist.
他简直是个反社会加自恋狂。
You know what made me laugh that Josh Radner did?
你知道乔什·雷德纳做什么让我笑出来了吗？
What did Josh Radner do?
乔什·雷德纳做什么了？
When she was telling her stories that would stop going on, and he was just like looking at her like, oh my god, this is great stuff.
当她一直在讲那些没完没了的故事时，他那种看着她的眼神，就像在说，哦天哪，这太棒了。
Yeah, that was really funny.
对，那真的太搞笑了。
Before the illusion was shattered, that he did some very good reacting there, and he's just in.
在幻灭之前，他那里的反应戏演得非常好，他完全投入进去了。
Because she's beautiful.
因为她很漂亮。
Yeah, she's fantastic.
对，她太棒了。
She's cool, and he likes her at that point, and I took note of that.
她很酷，而且那个时候他是喜欢她的，我当时就注意到了这一点。
That was some good acting.
那演技真的很棒。
Yeah.
对。
I didn't want to joke at first who said that oh my god, Robin.
我一开始不想开玩笑说“天哪，罗宾”。
It was, yeah, it was right.
那是，对，没错。
Yeah, I don't want to joke at first.
对，我一开始不想开玩笑。
That's another dark Steven.
那是史蒂芬的另一个黑暗梗。
I really liked the anti kind of romantic montage that mirrors the first one where Ted's just walking away and jogging up ahead.
我真的很喜欢这种反浪漫的蒙太奇，它呼应了第一集，泰德只是走开然后超前慢跑。
Yeah.
对。
It was really funny.
真的很搞笑。
You had some good.
你准备得挺好。
This is a good episode.
这是一集好剧。
You were a decent place to say that I met Lindsey.
你当时处在一个挺合适的时机说我遇到了林赛。
at this episode, and we, this is not, who that friend was talking about, but we went out a couple times and we really were drawn to each other and then we reconnected a couple months after this episode and then we were together for about a year.
就是在这集拍摄的时候，我们——虽然不是那个朋友谈论的对象，但我们约会了几次，确实被彼此吸引，然后在这集播出几个月后我们重新联系上了，之后我们在一起大约有一年时间。
And it was wonderful.
那段经历太美妙了。
She's a wonderful, if she, I doubt she's listening, but hello, Lindsay, if you're out there.
她是个很好的人，如果她——虽然我怀疑她不会听这个播客，但嗨，林赛，如果你在听的话。
She's very talented and funny.
她非常有才华又搞笑。
She's great.
她太棒了。
Very talented, very funny.
非常有才华，非常搞笑。
Did you meet her through this episode or did you met her before?
你是通过这集认识她的，还是之前就认识？
Okay, yeah, yeah.
好的，对，对。
She was great.
她太棒了。
She was a delight to work with us.
和她合作简直是一种享受。
Yeah, yeah, I thought she was just a, she was wonderful.
对，对，我觉得她真的非常好。
And I loved, why do you think I called her Chewbacca?
我最喜欢的是，你觉得我为什么叫她楚巴卡？
Oh my God, because it's the, she wears lots of shiny belts and I resemble a young Harrison Ford.
哦天哪，因为她戴了很多闪亮的皮带，而且我长得有点像年轻时的哈里森·福特。
Yes, which I thought was funny.
是的，我觉得这很有趣。
And now Marshall made a Harrison Ford joke, yet again, how I made your mother a prophecy.
现在马歇尔又开了一个哈里森·福特的玩笑，这简直又是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的一则预言。
It's serious prophecy.
这真的是神预言。
It's freaky, it's genuinely freaky.
太诡异了，真的极其诡异。
There's a bunch of those.
这样的例子还有一堆。
Yeah, I loved how loud the cotton candy was that Lily was.
对，我喜欢莉莉吃的棉花糖声音有多大。
Oh my God, that specific sound was genius too.
哦天哪，那个特定的音效简直绝了。
Like I can't even, it was, there's some very good sound work, but I remember having to torture the sound mix people being like, yeah, Barney bringing in the CD software, old tech alert.
我甚至无法形容，这其中包含了很多优秀的音效工作，但我记得我当时不得不折磨音效混音师，跟他们说，对，巴尼搬进CD软件——老旧科技警报。
I like the Patriot Act reference was really funny.
我喜欢那个关于《爱国者法案》的梗，真的很好笑。
Also, Marshall's paying of checks sounded like old spirituals, like old, like he was really diggin' deep.
还有，马歇尔数支票时的声音听起来像老式黑人灵歌，就好像，老天，他真的挖得很深。
Siegel just channeled these things.
西格尔就是能把这些东西信手拈来。
Like just he was, he had different genres going on.
就像他当时那样，他搞了不同的风格。
He had, yeah, he had all, he covered a lot of musical basses with those songs.
他确实，他把所有的，他用那些歌曲涵盖了很多音乐流派。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And the apple orchard one has this, rah, kind of like old, like a little ragtime, a little old Broadway, there's, it's genius.
那个苹果园的歌有种，啊，有点像老派的，有点像微型雷格泰姆，有点老百老汇的感觉，这简直是天才。
I know.
我知道。
All right.
好吧。
Yeah, I mean, you guys, you guys had a lot of different comedy traditions to plunder from, and when you use them all.
对，我的意思是，你们，你们当时有那么多不同的喜剧传统可以借鉴，而且你们把它们都用上了。
This was a good one.
这一集很不错。
This is a good Gantt group episode.
这是一个很好的盖特团伙集。
Everyone's on the same topic.
每个人都在讨论同一个话题。
One big idea, two mysteries that are related.
一个大主意，两个相关的谜团。
And it also deepened the lore, and it also every bit in here, in some ways gave you a different weapon for later, like a different comedic weapon for later.
而且它还加深了背景设定，这里的每一个段落，在某种程度上都为你以后准备了一个不同的武器，就像以后的一种喜剧武器。
You could always go back to one of the spoiler alert things for a very solid laugh.
你随时都可以回到某个剧透警告的事情上去，收获一个非常实在的笑声。
And they all came from character, but in some way, Lilies is just ridiculous, I guess, but like they, yeah, I feel like, I don't know that that one ever returned.
而且它们都源于角色，但在某种程度上，莉莉的那些只是有点荒谬，我猜，但就像它们，对，我觉得，我不知道那一幕是不是再也没出现过。
Yeah, I'm not sure we ever brought that one back.
对，我不确定我们是否把那个带回来了。
That might have been the one up, but all the other ones kind of came from character.
那可能是唯一的一次，但所有其他的都算是源自角色。
But I like, yeah, I like this one.
不过我喜欢，对，我喜欢这个。
This is a good, this is a good, the mini mystery and the filling in of the lore.
这是一个很好的，这是一个很好的迷你谜团和对背景设定的丰富。
These are two, we've discovered and rewatching.
这两点，我们在重看时发现了。
Those are two real hymium strengths and we had them both.
那是两个真正的“老爸老妈”的优势，而我们两样都有。
And again, really about, about something, like about something that if you're, if you're living living in a society with friends and trying to have relationships like this is an episode that you will relate to.
再说一次，这确实关乎，关乎某些事情，比如如果你，如果你和朋友生活在社会中，并试图维持这种关系，这就是一集你会深有同感的剧。
Yeah.
对。
And you could argue it either way.
你可以从任何一个角度来辩论。
You know, it wasn't right to say it was wrong to say it that Ted Ted spoils it for someone else moving forward.
你知道的，说这样不对，说泰德这样做不对，因为泰德把后来的情节对其他人剧透了。
So the sort of chain of spoiling continues.
所以这种剧透的链条还在继续。
Well, it's so high stakes like it's so high stakes.
噢，这赌注太大了，就像赌注太高了。
Every girlfriend Ted has is so high stakes, especially for Marshall and Lilly, because it's the front, it's the front porch, you know, it's the front porch and they don't want to listen to her blabber on forever on the porch when they're 90 when they're in the home together.
泰德交往的每一个女朋友赌注都太高了，尤其是对马歇尔和莉莉来说，因为这是前廊，你知道的，这是前廊，当他们九十岁一起待在家里时，他们可不想听她在前廊唠叨个没完。
on together or the way we make them look they're 57 but they look 90 we are up to one of our favorite segments on the show we call it the sea block this is the sea block and we don't know why we do that but we like it so we we like to open the show the voice note from from you guys and we close the show is this NPR what I don't know what it just really call for you know what it is.
一起待着，或者按我们让他们看起来的那样，他们才57岁但看起来像90岁，我们迎来了节目中最喜欢的环节之一，我们叫它C段，这就是C段，我们不知道为什么要这么做，但我们喜欢，所以我们喜欢在节目开始时播放你们发来的语音便签，然后在节目结束时播放，这是NPR电台吗？我不知道这到底叫什么，你知道这是什么。
This is for our nighttime listeners were down shifting we are bringing it down to the adrenaline of the early sessions and we're bringing we're bringing it down to the sea block and if you would like to send us a voice note or a written note about your love of how I may mother, whatever the show means to you.
这是为我们的夜间听众准备的，我们在降低节奏，我们在把气氛带回早期节目录制时的那种肾上腺素水平，我们在把它带到C段，如果你想给我们发一段语音便签或者文字便签，讲述你对《老爸老妈浪漫史》的热爱，或者这个节目对你意味着什么。
We love to hear from you.
我们很乐意听到你们的声音。
Go to HWMYM, how we made your mother.com.
访问HWMYM，how I made your mother.com。
Go to contact and follow the directions.
点击联系并按照说明操作。
It's very easy.
非常简单。
And we are going to conclude today's show with a letter from Samir in Brookline, Massachusetts.
今天节目的最后，我们将以马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩的萨米尔（Samir）的一封信来结束。
Conan O'Brien's hometown.
柯南·奥布莱恩的家乡。
Yeah, and I'll just say that as you'll see what this letter is gonna bring up is the fact that a lot of people are just finding this podcast right now, which we love.
对，我只想说，正如你们接下来将在这封信中看到的，很多人现在才刚刚发现这个播客，我们对此非常喜欢。
We love they're finally here in season three.
我们很高兴他们终于在第三季来到了这里。
Please obviously tell your friends about it.
请务必把这个节目告诉你的朋友们。
We also want to honor the fact that just because you have found us later on, we know you have a lot to say about seasons one and seasons two.
我们也想表达这样的敬意：仅仅因为你们是在后来才发现我们的，我们知道你们对第一季和第二季有很多话要说。
We don't want you to feel like we don't want to hear your ideas from before, from the past.
我们不希望你们觉得我们不想听你们以前、过去的想法。
So Sameer is going to do that for us.
所以萨米尔正要为我们这么做。
He found us recently.
他最近才发现我们。
I'm glad.
我很高兴。
But there's so much to say about all the stuff you missed.
但关于你们错过的一切，有太多的话要说。
So he's trying to- I hope it's compliments.
所以他试图——我希望都是赞美之词。
So this is from some here in Brooklyn, Massachusetts, greetings.
这封信来自马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩的萨米尔，问候。
I love him.
我爱他。
I'm a 54-year-old guy who went to the same high school as Craig.
我是一个54岁的家伙，和克雷格上的是同一所高中。
What high school is that, Craig?
那是哪所高中，克雷格？
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
But it would be a little bit older than he was a four-year-year, so I wouldn't, I was, my brain is raising Schreiber High School in Port Washington, Long Island, but we would be right.
但我要比他大一点，他比我小四年，所以我不会，我是，我脑子想的是长岛华盛顿港的施赖伯高中（Schreiber High School），但我们应该会。
We would have maybe overlapped by a minute, but very, okay, I would have been just coming in when he's leaving.
我们可能只重叠了一分钟，不过没关系，好吧，我进校的时候他刚好要离开。
continues.
继续。
I watched the show through its entire initial broadcast when my girlfriend and then wife Julie lived on the Upper West Side and then in Brookline, Massachusetts.
当我的女友、后来的妻子朱莉住在上西区然后搬到马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩时，我完整观看了该剧最初的整个播出过程。
I watched it again with my kids several years ago and I've seen scattered episodes again when my daughter Ella rewatched it.
几年前我和我的孩子们又看了一遍，当我的女儿埃拉重看时我又零星看了一些剧集。
I was thrilled to hear an ad for William, how we made your mother a couple of weeks ago and then Crestfallen a couple days later.
几周前听到《威廉，我们是如何创作你母亲的》（William, How We Made Your Mother）的广告时我很兴奋，但几天后却感到沮丧。
When I found out I had missed over a season and a half.
因为我发现我已经错过了整整一个半季。
I'm catching up.
我在赶进度。
But I'm sad I missed my chances to participate in the discussion so far.
但我很难过，我错过了迄今为止参与讨论的机会。
It's not too late.
现在还不晚。
Here we are.
我们在这呢。
We're discussing you right now.
我们现在就在讨论你。
By regret that having missed out is so great that I'm going to risk alienating myself and getting all subsequent emails trashed, unopened by using this first one to make a comment on your first few episodes through the Blue French Horn nay pilot episode.
因为错过而产生的遗憾是如此之大，以至于我甘冒疏远自己、让所有后续邮件都被当成垃圾邮件且未被打开的风险，用这第一封信来对你们的前几集发表评论，一直追溯到蓝色圆号也就是试播集。
A good portion of those episodes talked about what made him different and why the viewers who called and wrote and loved it so much.
其中相当一部分剧集都在讨论是什么让这部剧与众不同，以及为什么那些打电话、写信的观众会如此深爱它。
I've recommended hymnium to many people over the years, and I always felt disappointed.
这些年来，我向许多人推荐了《老爸老妈》，但我总是感到失望。
It felt important to me to convey why it was so good, and that it was good in a different way from other sitcoms we would talk about.
我觉得有必要向他们传达为什么这部剧这么好，以及它与我们谈论的其他情景喜剧相比，好在不同的地方。
I needed to get them to appreciate what was going on here, and I couldn't do it.
我需要让他们理解这里面究竟发生了什么，但我做不到。
Listening to how we made your mother so far is a welcome opportunity to make a more informed go at it.
听《我们是如何创作你母亲的》到现在，是一个难得的机会，让我能对它进行一次更深入了解后的尝试。
Hymnium didn't teach me anything foundational, or get me through anything, or change the path of my life for the better.
《老爸老妈》没有教给我任何基础性的东西，也没有帮我度过什么难关，或者让我的生活轨迹变得更好。
Yet, I still think I have as deep a love and connection to the show as those listeners who called or wrote and telling you how it did those things for them.
然而，我仍然觉得我对这部剧有着和那些打电话、写信告诉你们这部剧对他们产生这些影响的听众一样深厚的爱和连接。
Okay, almost as deep.
好吧，几乎一样深。
Another clue to what makes the show so special is Matt Rice's reason for his immediate and unique reaction to him, him, among your new series ideas.
关于是什么让这部剧如此特别的另一个线索，是马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）在你们的新剧创意中对《老爸老妈》做出即时且独特反应的原因。
Another was the divided industry reaction as you shopped and started the show and the common threat of those who, quote, got it.
另一个线索是，在你们推销和开始制作这部剧时，业内截然不同的反应，以及那些“看懂了”的人的共同点。
And then there were your observations about the audacious vulnerability of Ted's character, which we see so well written and acted in that pilot speech after he fucks it up with Robin, and Craig admitting how he felt evil casting calamities in their path.
还有你们对泰德这个角色那孤注一掷的脆弱性的观察——我们在那个试播集里他在把跟罗宾的关系搞砸之后的演讲中，看到了这种被写得极好并被完美演绎的脆弱性——以及克雷格承认他在他们的人生道路上安排那些残酷选角的恶趣味感。
Previously, I felt the closest I came to identifying what makes the show special is when I would tell people that the writers and the characters know it's all about the story.
在此之前，我觉得我最接近于指出这部剧特殊之处的时刻，是我对别人说，编剧和角色都知道这一切都是为了这个故事。
This was something my friends and I had been saying through our 20s, it's for the story, from some ill-advised and quickly hopeless adventure I wish I could remember.
这是我和朋友们在整个二十多岁时一直在说的一句话，“为了故事嘛”，源于某次不明智且很快陷入绝望的冒险，我都希望自己能忘掉它。
Even after beefing it up into a folk philosophy, it was obviously inadequate.
即使把它包装成一种民间哲学，它显然也是不够的。
After listening to how we made your mother, here's what I think I missed.
听了《我们是如何创作你母亲的》之后，以下是我认为我所错过的内容。
There are two kinds of storytelling.
讲故事有两种。
One is to get something.
一种是为了得到什么。
Claps, laughs, ticket sales, ratings, clicks.
掌声、笑声、门票收入、收视率、点击量。
Something that always comes down to money or celebrity.
归根结底都是关于金钱或名声。
It's transactional.
它是交易性的。
The other is caring.
另一种是关心。
It's storytelling to people you care about as a way of caring for them.
它是向你在乎的人讲故事，以此作为关心他们的一种方式。
You're gifting them something.
你在向他们赠送礼物。
Sometimes it's just respite, but usually and always if the story is nine years long, it's more than that.
有时这只是一种喘息，但通常也是，如果一个故事长达九年，那就远不止于此。
Of course, the two can overlap, but for any given story, I think it's pretty clear which is primary.
当然，这两者可以重叠，但对于任何特定的故事，我认为哪个是主要的相当明显。
I think him, Yum, was one of the rare sitcoms where caring storytelling was primary.
我认为《老爸老妈》是罕见的情景喜剧之一，其中以关怀为核心的故事讲述占据了主要地位。
Then what a generous comment.
多么慷慨的评论啊。
I love that breakdown of, and you are trying to do both.
我喜欢这种剖析，而且你们在努力做到两点。
We wanted to be a hit.
我们想要成功。
We wanted to stay on the air.
我们想留在电视上。
We wanted to stay alive.
我们想活下去。
We had to think commercially, because that was them's the rules.
我们必须从商业角度考虑，因为这就是游戏规则。
But I do think the deeper and more primary thing was what resonates with humans, and if that came across that, that means a lot.
但我确实认为更深层、更根本的是能引起人类共鸣的东西，如果这一点传达出来了，那就意义重大。
Thank you for that message.
谢谢你的这段话。
That means an awful lot.
这意义太重大了。
That's what we were trying to do.
这正是我们一直在努力做的事。
I mean, I think one thing you'll hear from the show, from Craig, from me and from other people who were deeply involved in the making of it, we did care.
我的意思是，我想你会从节目中、从克雷格、从我以及其他深度参与制作的人那里听到的一点是，我们真的很在意。
We cared a lot, and I'm glad that That comes through, you know?
我们在乎得不得了，我很高兴这一点能传递出来，你知道吗？
Yeah, me too.
对，我也是。
And that's, I think that's why we're still here talking about it, it's why we're all still friends, and that is the type of art we want to hopefully still be making, and that's the spirit of this very podcast.
我想这也是为什么我们现在还在讨论它，为什么我们所有人依然是朋友，这也是我们希望继续创作的那种艺术，正是这个播客的灵魂所在。
Yeah, and I am, we are signing off in the spirit of great optimism that in an hour and 15 minutes, Craig Thomas and I will be having dinner together.
对，而且我在，我们带着极大的乐观情绪结束这期节目，一个小时十五分钟后，克雷格·托马斯和我将一起共进晚餐。
I think we'll now have talked about this dinner in like four or five episodes.
我觉得我们这顿饭已经在大概四五期节目里聊过了。
This will like cover months.
这跨度得有几个月吧。
People will be hearing about this into the fall.
大家甚至到秋天还会听到这件事。
We'll have to follow up and say how the dinner went after.
我们之后还得跟进一下，说说晚餐吃得怎么样。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
There's a lot of pressure.
压力很大啊。
A post-mortem.
还得来个复盘。
What if we sit across from each other and I'm just like, I got nothing?
要是我们面对面坐着，然后我脑子一片空白怎么办？
I know, it's like we're talking all the time on a computer screen and we're just, it doesn't track carry over to real life.
我知道，就像我们一直在电脑屏幕前聊天，然后，它不一定能延续到现实生活中。
I'd be like, you sure?
我会觉得，真的吗？
You're in person.
你就在眼前。
We're, it has been a minute since I've actually seen you in person, which is fucking absurd because you're 20 minutes from me.
我们，我已经有一会儿没真正面见过你了，这他妈太荒谬了，因为你离我只有20分钟路程。
Guess what, I'm coming your way.
你猜怎么着，我要去找你了。
I'm coming to Brooklyn, that's how much I love you.
我要去布鲁克林了，可见我有多爱你。
Yeah.
好。
All right, everybody, we love you all too.
好了，各位，我们也很爱你们。
See you soon.
回头见。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请宣判我无罪，在纽约市。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈的幕后故事》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies网络和Audyssey呈现与发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
本节目还由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西担任执行制片人，并由我，亚历克·莱夫担任制片与剪辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, Appointed Blue Studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作与混音师是来自Appointed Blue Studios的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的Gen Z大师、数字内容制作人是艾米莉·布隆伯格，副制片人是凯瑟琳·格罗夫。
Artwork by John Morrow Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗创作，请在Apple Podcasts或你首选的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
这真的对传播节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，并有克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基的附加音乐。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别鸣谢萨姆·西博尔德和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目不可或缺的重要部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在Substack上订阅乔什·拉德纳的Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, Wherever Books Are Sold and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《事情不是这样的》（That's Not How It Happened），各大书店均有销售，并可在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读他已发表的其他文章。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father's Society on Substack.
你还可以在Substack上订阅我自己的《已故父亲协会》（Dead Father's Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
想要了解如何为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金这一本节目的持续公益活动贡献力量，
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上会跳舞。
Real question, it just hit me.
真心发问，我突然想到了一个问题。
Am I in love with you?
我是不是爱上你了？
We're just New York City.
我们只是纽约市。